this is the fourth in a new series of
videos that are designed specifically to
help those who want to engage in
self-directed study of philosophy and
each of these videos we focus on one
particular philosopher or a
philosophical tradition and I walk you
through a number of things that I hope
will be helpful to you like what text to
take a look at what order to study them
in issues that you should be concerned
about issues that you don't have to
worry about some advice about how to
read texts and format and what things to
keep in mind and we also talked about
the importance of the the figure or the
tradition or school whatever it happens
to be this time we're focusing on one of
the great schools of ancient philosophy
which emerges in the Hellenistic period
the epicurean school which of course has
its origin in this guy-- Epicurus
although you can say it traces back a
little bit further at least in some of
its origins to Democritus on who we
don't know that much about so we're
going to look at a lot of key features
and I'll give you some what I hope to be
useful advice if you are a lifelong
learner or somebody who's studying
things on the side and wants to work at
things on their own outside of a
strictly academic setting
I always like to start by answering a
very important question and a very
legitimate question why should I bother
studying the Epicureans in the first
place so they're long dead why should I
care about it well you know one quick
answer to that is they're not actually
long dead the originators of it but
there's there is a contemporary
epicurean movement which has adherents
all over the world and Facebook groups
and websites and they get together and
study and practice that bacteria and
philosophy and there is a literature
devoted to that but let's put that aside
for the moment we'll get back to that in
a little while why do you want to study
at the Curia and philosophy and what
answer could be well I've heard that
it's a really important early school and
so I want to sort of you know make sure
I don't fail to check off any of the
boxes in the list of people who I ought
to study that's perfectly legitimate if
you don't know anything about the
Epicureans up to this point and you say
well I know that they're important
because they see them in chapters that's
great why are they in the chapters well
because they were in fact one of the
more important schools in the ancient
world so you know just on its own basis
if you want to know something about
ancient philosophy you can't skip over
the Epicureans there's another thing
that you should keep in mind as well
so although the Epicureans you know
their their fortunes
you know wax and wane and at some points
in time they're practically either off
the scene or at least invisible you know
keeping their heads down they do have
these these recurrences throughout
history and they're taken seriously not
just by ancient philosophers or really
in the culture in general epicureanism
had a major impact on you know Roman
culture for example it's not just that
you you also see them you know as they
pop up and reassert themselves they're
part of a cultural conversation so even
people who aren't
tracted to Epicureanism as such are
referencing the Epicureans and so it's
very useful to know well what are the
Epicureans actually think if you want to
you know David Hume for example has an
essay specifically about the epicurean
philosopher and you can you can bet that
you know Hume had Epicureanism in mind
in thinking about other things later on
we're gonna see people like Marx or John
Stuart Mill defending and reinterpreting
the Epicureans Thomas Jefferson was
willing to call himself an epicurean so
we might want to think about you know
that sort of history of ideas area and
and the matter of influence but when it
comes to philosophical schools and
thinkers there's another really good
reason why we ought to study them and
that's you know more than just well they
influenced a lot of people or they you
know they're they're part of the culture
that that I have to know about if I want
to say that I understand the history of
ideas their ideas are interesting that
that's part of why their texts became
classics so the Epicureans introduces to
a perspective that is thoroughly
materialistic and hedonistic which means
that then they have to try to account
for all sorts of other things that
wouldn't seem to fit in that perspective
and you can decide whether they're more
or less successful in doing that but
it's clear that they certainly made an
effort to do that and they're thinking
out a way of living that would be based
on a certain set of understandings about
pleasure and pain and what leads to
pleasure what what helps to take away
pain what leads to pain as well that we
should avoid how to balance these off
against each other
you know what requirements of justice
are and how they fit in with that and
even the question about relationships
and friendship we also see that the
Epicureans devoted a considerable amount
of thought
and study - all sorts of other topics
like the emotions and its relationship
to rationality or what the good life is
things that the other philosophers are
concerned with as well so it's really
worth spending some time learning what
the epicurean position is the one other
thing that I'll say is epicureanism
likes a stoicism or certain
understandings of Aristotelian ism or
platonism or some some other
philosophies is a philosophy of life
that means that it's something that we
would look at not just as a set of
doctrines but we think about well what
would it be like to actually live this
way because that was one of the key
impetuses for for epicureanism catching
on why people you know embraced it so
that's something to keep in mind as well
and if you're looking for a philosophy
of life which I think many people are as
they're studying philosophy I know I
certainly have been at earlier stages in
my own studies that's part of what got
me into philosophy in the first place
then you might want to look at
epicureanism not necessarily to to
embrace it but at least they have if
there is an option so those are some
good reasons for studying epicureanism
the next set of questions that people
typically want to ask me and their great
questions although you may not be super
happy with the answers that I'm going to
give have to do with what texts and what
translations what additions you ought to
get and start with and like many ancient
philosophers Epicurus has been
translated multiple times
and i'm not going to endorse one
particular translation over another in
part because when it comes down to it if
I want to read up Acuras in the Greek
that's that's what I do
I actually simply go to my Diogenes lair
tastes you know book ten which is all
about Epicurus and to a certain extent
the epicurean school as well and it's
got the facing pages but you know for
you whatever Edition you can get your
hands on it is quite all right there's a
number of them out there you should
actually compare them against each other
there's online translations that you can
get and not pay a cent for that there's
many other translations that you can get
when it comes to other authors in the
epicurean canon then you know you might
be a little bit more restrained like
when we talk about Phil Oh Phil add Amos
for example well there's not many
translations of his works because
they're in the process of being
translated and I don't know whether
alternate translations are going to be
coming out because I don't run the
project right but you know when it comes
to say Lucretius you know there you a
lot of options as well I wouldn't worry
over much about getting the right
translation or the right addition get
something that you can sink your teeth
into you're going to be reading and
rereading it and going back over it if
you're really spending time with the
epicurean tradition anyway so that we
can kind of put to the side I do want to
say a few things about the availability
of epicurean literature though and this
will raise some questions
later on that will address as well but I
just want to sort of set it out right
now
so I mentioned Diogenes Laertes Diogenes
lair taste was a intellectual biographer
that is he
he wrote a set of books that he called
the lives and opinions of the
Philosopher's and in it he's telling us
you know what the Philosopher's did
where they came from the biography some
of their bomo or funny sayings
you could you could call them and a lot
about their doctrines in the case of
Epicurus we really owe a massive debt to
Diogenes why well because there are so
few works by Epicurus who has supposed
to have been one of the most prolific
authors of antiquity there are so few
works of his that have actually survived
and and we may in fact be able to find
them sometime you know tucked away
somewhere and that would be great but
for the time being all we really got are
what Diogenes preserved in this part of
his work now what day a genies did
because he liked Epicurus he thought he
was so cool he actually wrote down
verbatim what Epicurus had to say about
a few things so there's what we call
these the you know principle doctrines
there's a couple different you know
sovereign Maxim's is another way of
translating it basically it's sort of a
list of epicurean sayings that come from
Epicurus and then three letters we also
have his will in there and and you know
some other discussion as well but that's
that's pretty much it and that was it
until they discovered another alternate
set of of Maxim's or doctrines called
the Vatican sayings they found it in the
Vatican not because it was being hid
away but just because they don't
actually know what's in their library a
lot of the time and you know some of
this line line for line the same thing
as the principle doctrines that's what
we have and it's rather fragmentary we
also
we have you know some other literature
as well which I'm going to talk about in
just a bit but but we want to keep that
in mind now that's not totally unusual
for ancient literature we don't possess
most of what the Stoics wrote we don't
actually possess a lot of what Aristotle
wrote we know you know from Diogenes
Lyra taste and his list of books what
we've gotten what we don't have there
are there are some schools that we
possess nothing of so we're kind of
lucky that we have what we do I do want
to say one other thing as well
one main source for epicurean doctrines
and we could say epicurean literature is
in fact the opponents of or critics of
the epicurean school so you know Cicero
is a major figure in that Plutarch who
you may know from his biographies but
Plutarch was also a moral philosopher of
the middle plate in his school Seneca
Seneca in especially in his early
letters to Luc Ilyas is bringing up
Epicurus quite a bit Lucian the comedian
the satirist of some soda he you know
tells us quite a bit about the
Epicureans here and there and you know
others authors do as well like locked on
seus this early Christian writer who
talks about the Epicureans in several of
his works as well so you know when it
comes down to to the text you know these
practical questions which editions do I
need to get don't worry so much about
that get get your hands on some realize
that the perspective that you're going
to get on the Epicureans is a little
fragmentary and also some of it is
coming from critics if not outright
opponents of the epicurean tradition
how should you start what are the works
that you should begin with and then what
would you start looking at later on
after you've got you know a good solid
foundation established for your
understanding of the Epicureans I always
say go to original texts you know you
can read secondary literature if you
want to and we'll talk about that in a
bit but but I think if you shouldn't
deprive yourself of the opportunity to
actually read philosophy in its original
form or you know in translation of
course and get your your ideas straight
from the source actually that that cuts
out a lot of nonsense that you might get
from secondary sources and being overly
reliant upon them so who should you
start with well this is kind of a
no-brainer
Epicurus right now you may say well dr.
Sandler didn't you just say that we
don't actually have many texts by the
guy I did indeed but those are the ones
that you should start with so you want
to get yourself there's basically two
kinds of literature coming from Epicurus
himself right you've got these lists of
sayings and and they contain some claims
and that some arguments and some
distinctions that are very important in
epicurean thought you've got the you
know principle doctrines and you've got
the Vatican sayings so you want to get
your hands on those and those are a very
quick read because they're not very long
at all and then there's three letters
that you would want to get as well the
one that's probably viewed as most
important is the letter to man osseous
but there's also some letters that have
to do you know with some of the same
topics but also with with the Epicureans
conception of the physical world the
letter to Herodotus and the letter to
Pisces along with those I do think that
you want to get Diogenes lay our tastes
and you want and you can find that
easily online you can purchase a copy or
you can you can find translations of it
you know available for free so you you
want to read through chapter 10 or book
10
of Diogenes Lior tastes because before
he actually gives you his copied out
Epicurus he also does several other
things he tells you about
Epicurus and his history and he tells
you about his friends and the community
that he established and he tells you
about some of the things that people
said about him and why Diogenes thinks
these things are actually off-base he
also gives you the list of his his works
which is you know occupies more than one
page and then he tells you a bit about
the doctrines of the Epicureans and a
bit about what happened after Epicurus
shuffled off the mortal coil and and who
took over so you want to read Diogenes
Lyra taste as well another key work that
you're definitely going to want is
Lucretius this one's translated on the
nature of the universe it's often
translated on the nature of things de
rerum Natura Lucretia was an epicurean
poet but he's doing a lot of philosophy
really hardcore philosophy in this
poetic work and he's giving you a pick
Aryan doctrines he's also giving you a
different take on Epicurus where
Epicurus is this sort of savior figure
helping to you know free mankind of its
silly superstitions and fears and he's
responding to some of the critics
interestingly a lot of people think that
Cicero probably helped edit that that
works so Lucretius is another one Phil
Adiemus I mentioned the fill of Danis
project so Phil Adiemus was an epicurean
philosopher who's who's a little bit
before Lucretius and we discovered some
of his texts actually quite a few of his
texts on papyri in this place that that
is you know essentially had preserved
the text but not in great form and when
they first tried to unroll them I think
it was either in the late 1700s of the
early 1800s they screwed it all up so
then they are like oh we got to put this
stuff aside
and wait until we've got better
technology they do have better
technology now and they're slowly
opening up these texts and transcribing
Felidae missus Greek and there's a
filadyne lading and publishing his work
so we're actually in a very exciting
time I use phillyd a missus on anger
which unfortunately is a bit fragmentary
because the people who unroll that if we
screwed it up
III focus on that but there's also you
know some discussions of rhetoric
there's discussions of what's in Greek
called pomeriggio or Frank speaking and
so Phil Adiemus is another really
important source for us who else oh so
now we start getting well there's
there's one before we start thinking
about people like Cicero there's a
philosopher who inscribed a whole bunch
of epicurean literature and including
letters that he wrote on a wall his name
is daya Jenni's of Buena onda and he
created this inscription unfortunately
the inscription which you can find
translations of online is very partial
so it's it's quite fragmentary it would
be really cool if we actually have the
original copy of it but but we don't but
it adds a little bit to the to the
picture if you want something that
actually does present the Epicurean
position on some things you might
actually go to Cicero because Cicero
although he's hostile to the Epicureans
he does present their positions in a
more or less faithful way in the parts
where he's presenting it and then he'll
attack it after that
so you know if you want to know about
the epicurean theology you go to on the
nature of the gods and look at book 1 if
you want to know about the epicurean
views on morality and the virtues and
happiness and pleasure go to on moral
ends or on the ends book 1 and and you
know you'll you'll see him presenting it
through the mouthpiece of torque
Cuates who is an epicurean there's also
some interesting discussions in on fate
which is a fragmentary text but talks
about the epicurean view on freedom and
then one other thinker who I think I
could recommend but now we're getting
into sort of you know more advanced work
would be the the early modern
philosopher Pierre Gassendi who by the
way was a Catholic priest and an
epicurean so he's got an interesting
project you know a lot of reconciliation
going on cuz Cindy was not if you
remember his name it's probably because
you you're thinking of gases and stuff
like that he did do work in physical
science he was also a philosopher and he
was one of the people who wrote one of
the set of objections to de cartes
meditations Descartes didn't actually
like what he had to say and he does so
from an epicurean perspective so Gaston
D can be worth checking out and and
there's there's a you know two works in
particular not even sure if they're
actually translated one is his anima
animus adversely annum adverse Onias and
then the de vita a more ebooks
Epicurus libre octo there is translated
a concerning happiness short piece that
you can find on one of the epicurean
websites but kasundi is an interesting
guy and what he shows us is is the
adaptability of the epicurean doctrine
so you know where would you start you
know Epicurus I would get yourself
Lucretius I would probably say you know
Epicurious Lucretius Diogenes lair taste
Cicero's you know on the ends book one
that'll get you started and then you can
start getting into all these other
things as well and I mean the the good
news is it doesn't take you that long to
go through the epicurean literature but
that's also the bad news because we've
lost so much of it
there's a few things that I would say
are worth keeping in mind as you're
approaching these texts I'd have to do
with their genre and also in this case
with with their completeness so you know
one thing right off the bat that has to
do with the completeness is when you're
reading this stuff don't expect to find
like a full system so you know you've
got what we've got and you have to take
what we have and extrapolate from that
you have to do a bit of thinking things
through you know if we had Epicurus this
book on nature maybe we wouldn't have to
do quite so much interpretive work but
we don't have it so until we do finally
find a copy of it somewhere and then
translate it that's the situation that
we're in with each type of work you want
to keep in mind what its actual shanwa
is so Lucretius is is writing a
philosophical treatise but it's also
poetry and it's intended to do both
things poetry was used to teach back in
the day but you know some of what he's
writing the way that he's framing it is
so that it can actually fit meter by the
way Latin poetry not about rhyming Greek
and Latin poetry was really about the
metre of things so the word choice will
sometimes be a matter of what fits you
know
Epicurus writes these well he provides
us with these lists of doctrines that's
all they are it is lists of doctrines
they're not in any particular order you
could move them around if you want you
can actually see in the Vatican sayings
and the principal doctrines that that
some of the sayings are located in
different places letters are written to
particular people but there you can
think of them as sort of an open letter
intended for teaching purposes providing
the doctrines so there's that as well in
cicero's on the ends you get a fairly
systematic but but rather short
presentation
of epicurean doctrine and the mouth of
torquatus similarly his on the nature of
the gods you know you get you get some
epicurean theology I mean the Epicureans
by the way believed there were gods this
is a little bit of a side note they just
thought that the gods didn't care about
us the gods were blessed precisely
because they don't bother with human
beings right they they don't get
involved in that there's no Providence
or anything like that and Epicurus was
particularly concerned with making sure
that people understood that the gods are
not out to get you in part cause the
gods don't don't care their blessing
they don't get angry they don't get
envious they don't get all these things
that you know Homer or the other Greeks
we're saying that they they did when it
comes to other works you know we could
talk about the inscriptions and the
fragmentary nature of that same thing
with Phil O'Day --mess if you're if
you're able to get your hands on copies
of his works he's writing philosophical
treatises but sometimes they're
fragmentary so we you know with the
epicurean tradition perhaps more than
others we have to do a lot of filling in
the blanks and people do that in
different ways and there's more than one
legitimate way to do that so you don't
have to worry about like getting that
right just worry about you know trying
to understand the text that you're
reading the last thing that I do want to
say about this this issue of genre and
style and the fragmentary nature is as I
mentioned before
epicureanism is a philosophy of life
people embrace this not just because
they were like oh it's it's a cool new
form of philosophy purely theoretical no
there there was another important aspect
to it it helped inform the way that they
they ought to live and for the
Epicureans that meant generally sort of
withdrawing from society and you know
most relationships other than very close
relationships living together in
something almost like a communal so do
it on your own
and trying to arrange your life so you
enjoyed as many pleasures that wouldn't
get you into trouble and get pain so
Epicurus themselves is not big
sex for example or drinking you know as
many pleasures as you could have and a
life is free from trouble and pain and
fear and sorrow as possible and they
they viewed that as the good life and
they didn't just sort of set that up as
their ideal and then immediately get to
it there's a dialectic and back and
forth between reading and thinking and
applying it and then learning some
lessons from it and then rethinking what
you you've got there so keep that in
mind as you are trying to make sense out
of this philosophy I'm not saying that
you have to practice it what you don't
but you should imaginatively put
yourself in the position of a person who
might be practicing it and think about
what that sort of life would entail and
it'll help you understand the philosophy
better
now we get to the part of the discussion
where we focus on secondary sources and
literature which which might be very
helpful for you so when we think about
that there's a couple different kinds of
literature that we want to have in mind
so one thing that you might think of
right off the bat are histories of
philosophy and I've got cobblestone who
generally won't steer you to wrong
usually he's on point he gives you some
nice you know little bits and pieces and
passages of the Philosopher's
cobblestone actually developed these so
that he could teach his own students
and unfortunately in in this book on
ancient Greek and Roman philosophy you
can see how little space he devotes to
Epicureanism much of what you're getting
here is actually what you could find in
Diogenes Laertes and I would suggest
again you you you really do want to read
Diogenes Laertes because that's where a
lot of the stuff is coming from it's
kind of similar in many other histories
of philosophy precisely because we don't
have that much to work on you're gonna
find this stuff on epicureanism is going
to be rather short now you might also
look at say contemporary works more
popular works that discuss epicurean
philosophy and the epicurean school and
things like that and I do have one
really good recommendation for you and
I've got a recommendation you could say
against as well so let's start with that
a book came out fairly recently by
Greenblatt called the swerve and it was
referencing you know Lucretius and it's
about you know how the Renaissance came
out of the Middle Ages and as far as
like history of ideas go a lot of people
have pointed this out it's actually
pretty bad you you see the sort of
revival of this you know oh it was all
dark ages and then there was the
beautiful Renaissance
coming after that and these monks you
know we're trying to control everything
and most of that's nonsense I mean all
you got to do is read some medieval
literature to figure that out
right so I wouldn't go to the swerve to
learn about Epicureanism I do have a
book however which I'll actually be
reviewing in the near future I've had my
hands on it for quite a while the author
sent it to me very graciously and it's
quite good now there's some parts of it
where there's some things you you might
say I goes a little bit too far at this
but it's called tending the epicurean
garden by Hyrum Crespo and it's got a
lot of nice discussions drawing on you
know epicurean literature and trying to
adapt it for for modern times and giving
you exercises so this is represents I
mentioned there there is a contemporary
epicurean movement out there this is one
of the main people in that movement and
so you might want to get your hands on
this book that's at the level of popular
literature we might also think about you
know good secondary literature that's of
a more academic nature and and there's
there's quite a lot out there in terms
of articles that are quite good
you know I I'll mention not just some of
the other people who I'm going to be
showing you in just a sec but also Voula
suna who is one of the translators fillo
Danis she's got some really interesting
stuff but I do want to mention also
anthony long and and sadly they are they
are among the people who helped to sort
of put Hellenistic philosophy back on
the academic map within the
english-speaking world of course outside
of that there's you know French scholars
and-and-and German scholars much of
which doesn't get translated
unfortunately you know because it's it's
secondary literature I do have a few
reasons or at least fairly recent books
that I think
be quite good and they're not just about
Epicureanism they're about ancient
philosophy in general and the different
schools but they do each have some some
great sections on the Epicureans so I'll
begin with one of my favorites the
morality of happiness by Julia honest
who's a real giant in the field she's
got I mean there's a lot of really great
stuff in here but she's got some
sections specifically on the Epicureans
and not just in one part of the book
well you know over and over again she's
she's looking at the epicurean stuff and
she has got a lot of great articles on
epicurean tradition as well another
person who gets brought up quite a lot
who's also well worth reading
certainly this work Martha Nussbaum the
therapy of desire theory and practice
and Hellenistic ethics again you're
gonna find you know quite a few things
on Epicureanism there's a chapter
epicurean surgery and then there's
another one mortal immortals which is
about Lucretius the one on Seneca you
know to some degree is addressing the
Epicureans and then finally a book that
came out fairly recently 2006
Christopher gills the structure itself
and Hellenistic and Roman the thought
I'm a big fan of Christopher Gill really
great students of the the Stoics but he
also does good work the Epicureans as
well and there's a lot of cool stuff in
here about the epicurean notion of the
self reconstructing that so you might
find those sorts of things useful I
would also say you know when we're
talking about the Epicureans it might be
interesting to you to not focus just on
say recent or even you know 20th century
secondary literature and
reinterpretations of the Epicureans you
might also take a look at
the way the Epicureans were
reinterpreted not just in people like
ascend II but also more recent authors
John Stuart Mill is viewing the
Epicureans as precursors to the
utilitarian tradition that he belongs to
Karl Marx you know wrote his early work
his dissertation was on when Epicurus
right and and so there in Democritus
right and you know there's there's quite
a few other thinkers who are discussing
Epicurus and the epicurean sometimes
they're they're a little dismissive you
know for example Hegel's examination of
the Epicureans or Nietzsche's you know
almost dismissal of the Epicureans but
occasionally you'll find some some
thinkers like I mentioned David Hume has
a very interesting essay the on the
epicurean that you could check out as
well so you you might find that stuff
giving you interesting points of view
that you can consider and it'll also
help to sort of connect the
constellation in the history of ideas so
you'll see the effect that the epicurean
literature has had throughout its you
know the long history of philosophy and
its connection to other disciplines
over the years I've seen a lot of people
approaching philosophical schools and
thinkers for the first time and there
there are often some problems that will
arise that aren't really that that worth
worrying about let alone getting bogged
down in and with the epicurean school I
think that we can say that there's
there's some issues like that as well I
wouldn't allow myself to become overly
concerned with the polemics about
Epicureans and religion as I pointed out
the Epicureans were in fact theists they
weren't atheists although a lot of
people portray them as such but they
were theists of a really strange sort
who thought that God or the gods don't
really care about the world that the
divine is disconnected and I would you
know I mentioned the swerve and and the
sort of you know it gets criticized for
bringing in a Voltaire Ian's perspective
Voltaire was not a good historian a full
of philosophy or of ideas in general he
was one of the people who bought into
this you know it was all dark ages in
the Middle Ages
I would I would leave all that death
stuff aside I wouldn't worry about that
unless you're already you know
preoccupied with that it's just kind of
a distraction and it doesn't contribute
much to understanding Epicureanism or to
perhaps even trying it out in your own
life another thing that you don't need
to do is stake out a position on other
criticisms of Epicureanism so I
mentioned that like you know we know a
bit about Epicureanism from people like
Cicero or Plutarch or Lucian or even
locked-on so yes I mean if you're
reading locked-on see us more power to
you right kind of a rare taste these
days and you know you don't have to
worry about whether they're totally fair
have it right or anything like that in
order for you to you know acquire a good
conception of what the Epicureans
actually taught I mean it could be that
Cicero is being unfair I think he's on
to the Epicureans at points but we can
still learn from it we don't have to say
Oh a hostile critic therefore we dismiss
everything that would be really foolish
on our part right which from an
epicurean point of view it would be a
bad thing because the Epicureans stress
the virtue of prudence or practical
wisdom the opposite of which is
foolishness so I don't think you have to
worry about about that or and you don't
have to worry too much about whether
Marx or mill or Hume are getting the
Epicureans completely right just try to
learn from their their interpretations
and then as your is you acquire a better
and better understanding of it that's
when you can form those critical
judgments one other thing that I'll
bring up obviously the epicurean physics
is pretty much just as outmoded as the
Aristotelian one is you know you you
might say well wait a second didn't the
Epicureans you know come up with the
atomic doctrine well I mean Democritus
did and the Epicureans took it from them
but what they mean by atoms isn't
remotely close to what we mean by atoms
and the the epicurean physics you know
their conception of the physical
universe it's it's it's you know it's
nice to imagine but it's you know it's
not really close to natural science and
the president as a matter of fact the
Stoics might be closer than the
Epicureans with their concept of Talmud
and you know this notion of matter and
energy shifting back and forth that we
have but you don't need to worry about
that that is not something that has to
distract you from being able to read and
appreciate and understand these texts so
I would put those sort of issues aside I
table them until later unless you really
like to worry about that sort of stuff
so I do have a few final thoughts about
the epicurean school and Epicurus and
you know your own task of self-directed
study first off I want to say if you are
going to study Epicurus that's really
great and continue it on and it'll help
fill in the picture for you in so many
important ways you don't have to
actually agree with him any more than
you have to agree with Plato or the
Stoics or Cicero or any other thinker in
order to have a good solid appreciation
of what it is that they're saying and
understand how they fit in so that
that's an important thing I think you
know I read a lot of people and I teach
a lot of people who myself I don't agree
with but I find very interesting and the
Epicureans really are an interesting
Bunch
I think it's worth spending some time
thinking about what it is that they've
said and looking at their assertions and
arguments and distinctions it will make
you a better thinker whether you agree
with them or not so I you know want to
say one other thing too you know maybe a
word of encouragement if you're watching
this it's probably because you're
interested in carrying out some
self-directed you could say autonomous
study and you were just looking for a
bit of guidance in how to do that I
think that's really great and I hope
that you enjoy reading Epicurus and his
followers and successors and
interpreters and that it proves to be a
fruitful and useful you know way of
devoting yourself to philosophical study
you